the biggest fear I have right now is in
my popularity growth that people gonna
try to be like me I'm an enigma I was I
was in outer space I grew up in a very
different I grew up I'm a firt I was
born in the old country I'm more similar
to everybody's grandfather than I am to
them I'm a different animal don't do it
like me don't do it like you do it like
us in our buying into who we were and
how we could do it
you got your perspective hey everybody
really excited about today's podcast
excited about the book the more excited
about the gentleman that's sitting in
front of me Doug is a an iconic I like
using that iconic businessman and CEO in
the corporate world and was at the helm
of one of vaynermedia's earliest clients
Campbell's and an avid tennis fan which
is one of the first things I think about
with him but somebody had stayed in
touch with over the last decade who have
a lot of respect for and when him and
his team reached out and said hey we've
got a new book out we'd love to be on
the podcast I couldn't have been more
excited for this moment and so here we
are
LinkedIn community I know you're
watching live we're taking phone numbers
on Facebook where we're live as well I'd
really like to give some of you access
to Doug because I think the wisdom and
the experience and the blueprint that he
brings to the forefront is a valuable
one and I'm excited to give you context
I think a lot of times a lot of the
entrepreneurs and executives from this
show get enormous value of some of the
Great's that have done it and I feel
like Doug sits in that category and so
I'm really excited to see my friend
that's good to see you too Doug why
don't you give some context cuz I do
have an audience that I think we'll be
hearing about you for the first time and
I'm excited about that so why don't you
give a little 2 to 3 minute rant call it
a comic book number one origin story
stuff you can go all the way back to who
you were as a kid or going to your
professional stuff but take the floor
for three to four minutes for context
and we'll take from there sure I grew up
in a very modest household outside of
Chicago
and were you a Bears fan Oh big time
well Allen Robinson the star wide
receiver the Bears
just walked out of here two seconds ago
and I missed him we got to find him
so I'll go find him I gotta get him for
death he's here that'd be awesome
yeah what's done figure it out I don't
think we're moving in propping early
quick interrupts I'm just like if you
could get Rizzo or Chris Bryant here are
you examine these for you well speaking
of cups sports cards are back and I'm
buying Javier Baez rookie cards are
crazy oh yeah so go ahead all right
she's hot Chicago I grew up in Chicago
and migrated to the corporate world very
early on I tried to play professional
tennis that lasts at a nanosecond and
then discovered I couldn't make any
money went back finished my MBA when I
went to work in the corporate world
worked there for 40 years
some believe oh my first performance
review six months into my job you know
your boss signs it and that your boss's
boss had to read it read it and make a
comment my boss's boss on my first
performance Emily real quick this is
exciting story ready your six months in
where are you working what are you doing
at General Mills in Minneapolis and you
are a consumer I'm a brand management a
large consumer goods company what brand
are you want I was on Betty Crocker
potato buds and specialty potatoes and
then I moved on to Betty Crocker
brownies putting some pie crusts I I did
it all there you were a Betty Crocker
Chuck I was riding the back had a
message on the back panel from Betty
Crocker as well cross Betty Crocker so
you are Betty Crocker at some point I
was I love this my mother was in shock
she said what are you doing I'm saying I
tell there are many Crocker wrestle so
anyway six months in six months in I get
I have my first review and my bosses
plus the only line he writes is you
should be looking for another job
really first you know and I've moved to
Minneapolis Minnesota I don't know a
soul and it's cold as [ __ ] yeah it is it
was March it was we had it first the
first eighteen days I lived there
the high temperature was below zero so
he so it's below zero I'm getting
feedback you should be looking for
another job
I don't know anybody how'd you handle
that
I did all right with it good you know I
hit you know you have two choices fold
or double down and then I doubled down
and I was grinding it out how did you
learn from that well what's the what's a
takeaway from that was it about
interactions with your boss was it it
was or some other random insight I what
I learned from that probably was that I
could play through it
hmm but early on I was like a deer in
the headlights you know my first day at
work I went there off the tennis tour
and I had a everybody was wearing
pinstripe suits red ties white shirts
that was sort of them yeah this is
mid-70s and and I show up in a khaki
suit with a yet bright yellow shirt a
big wide madras tie and brown earth
shoes and a tan line from where I had my
headband and my plant you must add and
here I'm showing up at a button-down
collar place and did any funny comment
in the first 24 hours no but I still
looks I will tell you I started to look
like everybody else about three months
in I understand I spent probably the
first my entire time there my focus was
on fitting in because my feedback early
on was you're not fitting in so I was
trying to I was trying to figure out how
to make this work it was a whole new
world
it'd be like walking in here for the
first time in Europe yes the energy here
Wow yes steroids
yes but at any rate and I was trying to
fit in yes I understand I was trying to
figure out what did you like the work I
mean obviously stayed like 40 years like
amiibo more than the work was fine but
yet it was a party it was interesting
but the people I like I'm being part of
a large community just like you've got
here yeah being part of a larger gene
people give each other energy and if you
needed help you found somebody to help
you did you like playing doubles or did
you antenna so you liked more of a
singles aspect I I would both both if
your tennis player I was better at
doubles but if you're a tennis player
you're sort of a long funny way
you know because you're it's not a team
sport you know you're you're playing for
yourself yeah but so so so what happened
Lanyon eventually I got fired from that
job that's epic nine years nine years in
I went in I was working I had the
world's greatest job I was director of
marketing for Parker Brothers toys and
games Oh
nerf sport I had two little kids
nerf sports and her football their food
the green and white football is like the
most Americana for me because that's how
I became a Jets fan like the nerf spongy
nerf green and white football is like
one of the most near and dear things to
my heart we are a lot of us grew up with
little leather there but like that's
what it looked like
well now you you've gone upscale started
I want to be known as upscale anyway so
I went into my buses I went in to work
on a beautiful spring morning this is
now nine years nine years later up in
Boston and I and the receptionist said
the senior vice president marketing
would like to see you I go up to his
office and he said your jobs been
eliminated you'd need to be out of here
by noon simple as in nine years of my
career was over in a snap so real quick
you were General Mills for how long
before I was five years that that
gentleman zoned Parker Brothers I didn't
know that at the time got it and later
sold it to Hasbro eventually eventually
eventually they spun it off and then has
brought water yeah and that's so but you
know it was not healthy 30 I was 32 and
what like crushed that was that that was
the most deficit of my career no I had I
did you have a more I had two kids I'd
have very large mortgage real stuff you
know how am I gonna make some gonna go
home and tell my wife I'm dying I'm
dying I'm not to go I got to completely
go into that wound but like you're a big
boy now and had a lot of wait till
everybody hears he ended up being the
CEO of Campbell's so like he won but
like tell me about tell me about that
day who'd you call first
I'm actually very curious about that was
a I didn't Cory but you didn't you
didn't know what to do
yeah you know I was still you want to
talk me out of there by noon clean your
desk yeah clear your desk put it in a
box to anybody that you worked with no
because you were in a daze I yeah I was
did you go to a bar right up I went
straight home okay fair enough
told it to my wife my two kids my how
old it across the caps and this how did
the braces nonetheless it was hard what
happened next
next later they were so anxious to get
me out of the building they forgot to
tell me what my package benefit what my
package was so the head of so one of the
HR people called you and said I'd like
to fit you in yeah and I swore at him
and hung up the phone I you know I was
so pissed it sort of all came out
McEnroe came out yeah yeah there you go
yep and and after about two more hours
with my kids running around and the dogs
and the cats I thought I need to get a
job
I better call that guy back so I was
home so I I tell you I called him back
and that same day and they sent me to an
outplacement counselor who saved my life
saved my life
that same day I had had the worst
experience of my career and I mean that
over my 45 year career and that that
afternoon and I call my outplacement
concert guy by name and Neil McKenna
he answered this is before cell phones
yeah and before caller ID of course he
answers the phone whoever calls him and
he says hello this is neil mckenna how
can I help and he was there for me
completely I called him he said come
right on over we're gonna work through
this we got to focus forward I know this
is tough shopping but yeah and and he he
saved my life
Wow you know in in that moment and and
you know the funny thing was the first
thing he had me do and he we talked
about this right away he said I want you
to hand write your entire life story for
me and your family's story and I'm
thinking what are you talking about I
got to get a job I get you know you know
and you you and you want me to right
hand right you said yeah I want your
hand write it I want you to feel this
hand write your life story everything
everything you can think of leave
nothing out so I spent two weeks writing
my life
two weeks right my life what are you
have a book but what you know when
you're unemployed you have a lot of time
you have a lot of time so I I wrote for
two weeks and it was in third grade Suzy
Thompson and I like oh but I was writing
about my family coming to this country
finding their way and all of a sudden my
losing a job feel significant and I know
you found your family same perspective
and and I had a different perspective
and I'm looking at this and I'm saying
god I got to get over this you know this
is not the worst thing that's happened
to my family in in my history right yeah
and so it really helped me get some
perspective and then what happened this
is what was interesting he read the
story and he got to know me and within
another two weeks when we met he said I
don't get it this just doesn't add up
and I said why he said the person who
wrote this story is a fierce competitor
and is determined to make a difference
and you're showing up tail between the
legs yeah and as and you're not showing
that this the person I'm reading about
the person I'm meeting are two different
people I'm an introvert
I've even more then than I am now and I
wasn't talking unless spoken to I
started polite I was trying to fit in
make it work keep my job and do all this
defense yeah yeah yeah and I was
reacting to things and he said you've
got so much to offer go but you're
keeping it all bottled up inside and and
that's where the spirit of this book
started to be born because you know my
observation and we do a little story
David Brooks from the New York Times
writes about are you lizard living for
your resume or your eulogy are you
trying to get all the tangible things
you know the new car the corner office
are you living for that or are you
living for what they're going to say
about you when you're gone and he said
you get seduced living for your resume
and I started realizing that you got to
put your resume and your eulogy together
and it should be net together with a
sense of purpose that grows out of your
life story not out of all the testing
and
all this other stuff grows out of your
life story because as we see in the book
your life story is your leadership story
it's worth comes from I met with a young
woman that doesn't work here and she
wants to go do something and she's not
leaving because she's worried that her
resume is gonna show she only worked at
this place for six months I was like
it's 2020 nobody even [ __ ] reads
resumes what are you talking about yeah
that's a good point one night when I
lost my job it's like you were ashamed
that you lost a job and you didn't tell
anybody
people still her that way and and if
sigma's are real yeah so what happened
to career where did you get picked up I
ended up going to craft had a good run
at crafts where I moved to yep did you
love and did you go did you odd go to
Chicago I went back to Chicago tailed
between my legs to a degree because
that's where I grew up
yeah the craft was a job honey I had a
great great job there and it was the
entry point I was a category manager for
Kraft salad dressings mm-hmm
but I went on to the director of
corporate strategy at Kraft and then I
got recruited right after barbarians at
the gate right by KKR I gotta tell
everybody a little bit about this is an
iconic book in the corporate world I
want some of the youngsters and
entrepreneurs and outside the corporate
world to hear this tell everybody just a
few seconds on that iconic book and
story well this this was the story of
the second half of the 20th century it
was the world's largest OBO at the time
it was KKR buying RJR nabisco RJR was a
money machine tobacco machine they
acquired Nabisco and some other food
companies and built this massive
business but the handwriting was on the
wall for the tobacco industry and so
business started to soften KKR came in
and and made it the world's largest LBO
they planned to flip it in five years it
took us ten and they there was so much
money coursing through the veins of this
company that it was like the Wild West
of corporate spending and this is there
were sporting yeah there were stories of
the chairman who since passed sending
the corporate jet to pick up his dog on
the East Coast to come out to Mission
Hills California
for a golf tournament on the west coast
the dog the dog and we had we had we had
a team
he had assembled a team of the greatest
athletes of all time we know this story
the Johnny Johnny Unitas
all of them they really had no income in
their retirement they hadn't made the
money right and so they started they had
about 30 people on payroll who lived off
RJR nabisco and showed up at events and
everything else it was a larger payroll
I believe than the Yankees at the time
but it was the who's who of Hall of Fame
land because he loved the source and
just wanted hang out there yeah hang out
and you know it was a it worked
so they it was just amazing excess KKR
bought it we had a sort of wind all that
down because corporate governance was
getting in the way I mean you couldn't
do that some of that stuff and so yeah
we ended up taking a lot of cost out I
had a good run there the last five years
I was president abisco Foods running
that and then we sold that actually back
to Kraft who I had left and then I was
recruited to go help fix Campbell Soup
Company which was I was there for a
decade as CEO and that was great that
was wild I went in there and
headquartered in Canada how did that
feel remind me I apologize was it
directly to CEO yeah so how did that
feel how did it feel on the dawn of
knowing you're getting offered the CEO
job of one of the most iconic American I
mean this is now your full career at
this point right from from the early
days and Parker Brothers generally you
should be looking for another job
that's why should be cleaning I clean
out your desk did you try to our I'm
sorry you're like me did you try to find
those two guys that wrote that review
the night before you took yeah
hey Ronald I got something for you so
they know they I know they know did the
did it feel spent was that I was like it
was just it was a head under yeah but I
we had been acquired and I they knew I
was the the market knew I was not gonna
go back to craft right so so there were
several opportunities percolating I
ended up taking the Campbell were they
all CEO jobs or yeah got it so it's the
only one I could go to at that point in
your career I get it said I always said
you know I was I'm slow so I'm not as
fast as you but I had always said I want
to be a CEO by the time I'm 49
and what's that right and I was 49 when
it happened
you just you'll find funny Doug I speak
fast
my Energy's fast but I'm actually wildly
slow like even this company I'm running
now you know when we met way back when
for some org this has been built really
to buy brands I'm far more KKR far more
private equity than I am agency like I'm
actually going slow the Energy's high I
would argue that you 49 it's a pretty
young age at that time of year of that
era to be the CEO of something like a
much last it was it's pretty cool yeah
challenge with that kind of family
there's a lot of challenges going I
happen to have enough knowledge to know
like the Campbell's family died like
there's some day the family owned half
the company and they were five families
because it was third generation you know
yeah multiple generations
that's right tricky and we were
headquartered in the poorest most
dangerous city in the United States
Camden New Jersey challenged 75,000
people 70 murders a year and we and we
were being we were running it was a
canned soup company I mean our product
had been invented in the prior century
and was unchanged and I was saying I was
talking to our folks and I said well
don't we need to evolve and they said
you don't understand we can run canned
soup faster on our lines than anybody
else
you're like and I said but you know but
don't we need more and they said but but
we run our canned soups really fast
and so we evolved but the the company's
highlight for you personally in that
decade if I'm saying to you in that
10-year window hot tape you know I hit
strike you know we talked earlier about
your resume or eulogy that came together
for me
I showed up more authentically during
that era in in that era actually the
last five years at Nabisco I started to
mature I found my sea legs
I developed the courage of my
convictions that I probably hadn't had
before love that but being challenged at
Kate by KKR all the time yeah and the
people around there five years in I sort
of hit stride and said you know I can do
this so for you and then and then so at
Nabisco and then a Campbell I hit my
stride and that I I it became one you
know what I do today I live for my
resume but I very much it's in harmony
with the things I hope people say about
me someday
talk talk to me about the book and talk
to me about the awesome Amy who has a
big title Amy the awesome Amy is is
truly awesome I'll tell you I'm a 68
year old white guy I've heard and and
I'm writing this book and I would write
it like a 68 year old white guy respect
and and and I the book is designed and
we'll talk about in a minute to be
approachable for anyone right and I
needed help and Amy's a 30-something
gifted writer she writes all the social
she's editor in chief for Conant
leadership she writes all of our social
media content and what is called
leadership for everybody
excuse me what's call it leadership it's
it's what we're on to to promote
leadership that works in the 21st
century because most of the models is it
a consulting business is it we don't do
any consulting we don't make money I
don't take a salary we charge for a few
things to cover our costs if we more
than cover our costs we give it away and
we a legacy that's now for like seven
years for you and and and we're loving
it we're in it for all the runs the book
out the book just came out yesterday
congratulations who do you feel like
this is gonna hit most right in the
chest this can hit anybody from my kids
who are 33 35 and 38 mm-hmm on up and
that could actually I could actually
work with with college students the
beauty of this book is there is no one
right way to lead you you know and if I
talk about your leadership story is your
life story your life story is your
leadership story excuse me your life
story is unique so you should lead in a
unique way there are some timeless
principles that you should apply which
we talk about in the book but this book
is designed for you to create your
create your own blueprint you anybody in
this room and it will all be different I
have probably because I'm older I have
thousands of books I probably over a
thousand books in the office and there
are a thousand books to tell you how you
oughta lead yep and none of them
resonate with me completely they're good
a good idea here good idea there so what
we decided to do was write a book that
help people figure out how to lead in a
way that worked for them how much is
relationship with adversity and losing
self esteem self-awareness how many of
these you know well that's all I mean
it's all part of it this is complicated
if it was not complicated everything
would have been figured out already so
you know and the key to this book is and
all those other books it takes it's like
a diet after the holidays you have your
diet you say I'm gonna lose 20 pounds
and here we go my wife and I are gonna
start a diet we last about two weeks and
we say this is never gonna work it
doesn't fit in our life and the the way
we wrote this book was it has to nest
perfectly the change process perfectly
in your cockamamie life the way it
exists today anybody in your office all
of whom everybody feels swamped
hundred-percent swamped right it's
unbeliev a lot of people have one hours
worth of work feel like they're swamped
and I want to kick them in the face I
know it's true it's the human spirit
people fill their bucket with thought
let me make fun of myself I thought I
was the hardest-working guy going at 27
I laugh at that kid well you were pretty
hard work I was
but really you know you hit different
gears yeah that's right right it's true
it is around happiness from what you're
supposed to be doing
Amy jump in here for a second we just
want to ask go ahead don't be scared I
want to ask you a quick question from
your perspective cuz I think it really
matters and gonna help you know from
your perspective as this book was
written what what stood out to you what
was an aha for you maybe going through
the process which I think sometimes
happens or what was your ambition or as
you were listening and debating and
conjuring up with what when you now look
at this as a finished product where do
you go with like oh I'm really glad this
happened through the process or I'm
excited to see this group of people
absorb this and I'm excited like some
random thoughts on that front yeah so I
think one of the epiphanies was
anchoring this story in that moment of
Doug getting fired because it brings
somebody with such gravitas down to
earth yes relatable yes and it really is
the story of the worst day in somebody's
life how come you've been that day and
how do you get there yes and it's a
practical guide so when you look at a
story that big it can feel too big be
approachable so that's how we also had
kind of the Epiphany to make it really
practical people that I talk to my age
also feel swamped whether they only have
an hour of work or 70 hours yeah and
they're saying well how I don't feel
right I need to wait for the perfect
conditions to get started on a change
process what am I gonna feel ready
you're never gonna feel ready so this is
for you whatever how much do you feel
that is people's inability to have a
relationship with other people's
judgement I'm sorry say that one more
time sure
well I think it's it's a like to your
point and I couldn't agree with you more
like people come up with enormous
amounts of counterpoints to why this is
a time to do something that we mean
happier more successful mm-hmm and so
it's something I've been thinking about
my whole life I think one of the great
gifts that I was given is immigrant grew
up with very little and then on top of
it which is rare for immigrants bad
student writing that it that's an added
element which very early on gave me a
relationship with losing and being an
outsider that made me very comfortable
with not worrying about people's
judgment and I observe and I'm like
right they're scared to quit their good
job because they're unhappy because
they're worried about their mom's
judgment their husbands
their bestfriends judgment in what you
just said how much have you observed
what's your hypothesis on how much of
this is actually grounded in people's
inability to deal with other people's
judgment yeah that's a really good point
and you're actually lucky that you
failed early you got comfortable with
Reid there's a lot of people especially
who ascend to the levels of leadership
that the leaders Doug's talking to where
they're used to being really typing
right achieving and they're not
comfortable erect with something that's
imperfect so the message in this book is
forget perfection throw it out the
window it's not gonna be perfect you
just have to get going
perfection is a disguise for not wanting
to do absolutely it becomes it becomes
an excuse to just not even start a
hundred percent yeah I love that here is
this you can start right now with what
you've got right away and within a week
you can start to behave let's get one
question before we wrap up and then I'll
give you the floor to give some thought
to the last things we want to say before
we head out of here
yeah just makes sense you know it's
really funny podcast form book form you
know you know ultimately I think why I
wasn't a good student is my relationship
with reading I was never diagnosed but
it's clear to me you know I love that
people learn in different formats Adam
don't blow your only chance Adam this is
Gary Vaynerchuk
say hello to Doug and Amy are you good
what's your question brother you know I
just I know has done some research in
the past I'm actually reading a blog
right now it's kind of funny that I'm
even on this but I'm ready to blog right
now and it's about just talking about
employees within clients and just
showing appreciation and specifically
how to write the the perfect think you
know and I know
a little bit of Doug's history and how
he has written I believe over 30,000
thank-you notes
and I just kind of wanted to pick his
brain as far as like the impact of just
simply showing appreciation and being
genuine and like what that means and how
do you do that many suggestions with it
and yeah first you thank this guy for
knowing that history about you
well everybody I'm surprised you don't
Gary you know what I did know about the
thank-you notes
I know is the number is the number in
the range he's right aye I did know big
time on the thank-you notes I didn't
know as to I mean that is scale well you
know and and thank you when I Adam thank
you when I lob my exit my outplacement
counselor said you're gonna be a
horrible interview you're too shy you're
too introverted you got to figure out a
way to have a signature practice mm to
get a job figure it out so I started I
come here I'd meet 10 people I'd get all
their names while I was interviewing I
would go to the coffee shop next door I
would hand write a note to each of them
I would then walk it back to the coffee
to the front desk give it to the
receptionist and say could you deliver
these today I did that everywhere I went
Wow and I started to hire actress of
reaching out in a personal way it
doesn't have to be much receptionist had
never received a personal thank-you note
in their life from somebody calling on
the building that's amazing and so I
started doing that and then I went to
work at Campbell and even in Campbell
which was hemorrhaging 8 how to attend
things being done we're right we had to
make some real tough decisions let go
300 of the top 350 liters
he's never been done in fortune 500
history at the same time we had all
these people doing good work so I
started writing 10 to 20 short notes a
day to employees I was commuting two and
a half hours each way from New Jersey
down to Camden from Moores County down
to Camden I started
reading all the stuff that was going on
in the company and I would write notes
to these folks 10 to 20 a day six days a
week for a decade I was when I was
retiring the person from Forbes said how
many of these do I'm hearing about all
these notes from everybody how many
notes have you written I said I don't
know so we did the math during the
interview we did the math and figured
out just the Campbell employees I had
written 30,000 notes we only had 20,000
employees wherever you went in the world
we were in 38 countries we were marketed
on 125 countries wherever you went in
the world in a cubicle if I was to walk
up you would see a note from handwritten
note from man amazing just about every
person's cubicle somewhere you know
what's amazing about that Adam any any
parting shots cuz I'm gonna wrap up here
but thank you for that awesome and you
gotta make it personal and keep it short
awesome piggy for mud you got about you
know it's funny a lot of people don't
know this but in my transition from the
wine business to the tech world I reply
to every single tweet from 2007 to 2011
period anybody who replied to me and and
I think that's I mean but it's the same
game you play it was you know it makes
and context right you know like sending
a note aiming me like I liked your black
and white jacket that you wore in the
office today like when you actually are
paying attention when you actually know
a little something it's subtle little
things that really really tell you the
note I wrote we're not gratuitous I like
your jacket they were you delivered the
business on plan under budget or a nice
job with the deferred diversity Network
every note I sent was reaffirming our
company strategies and I was talking
performance but you know the the theme
was I'm gonna be tough minded on
standards we let a lot of people go but
I'm gonna be tender hearted with people
and the people that were getting the
work done they heard from me too I love
that so it's it's mine would've been
like a me good job we got the pages in
and I also like your jacket
well I think no mistakes I respect that
no I wish it's bad by the way by the way
it's back to the blueprint yeah it's
back to 11,000 books yeah it's I would
done that and you would have done this
and that's the biggest punchline but
because fear I have right now is in my
popularity growth that people gonna try
to be like me I'm an enigma I was I was
in outer space I grew up in a very
different grew up I'm a firt I was born
in the old country I'm more similar to
everybody's grandfather than I am to
them I'm a different animal don't do it
like me don't do it like you do it like
us in our buying into who we were and
how we could do it yeah it's it's your
story you right 100% our story and sent
all these leadership books sir here's my
story and here's how you should do it
it's wrong I'm with you it's wrong
parent now now if you're the kind of
learner that learns from other people's
examples that's why you went on to read
those books because you were able to get
a little here a little there at at 15 20
bucks a pop and if you're a quick reader
you can get value but whether it's a
free room people you can learn from you
know I I I met Stephen Covey when he was
Stephen Covey you know he was advising
presidents and I and he you know when
the student is ready the teacher appears
oh and he had a profound influence on me
so did Neil McKenna who was my
outplacement Connery right time right
place right human I mean there are
people to learn from always you have to
listen to your inner voice love and what
our observation is most people don't
know their inner voice they'd not say
him and reflected on it they don't think
you press it or they fear you out
because it doesn't even matter whereas
they fear it because they hear it but
they don't see it fitting into the
narrative that has been forced on them
right I'm here right now what matters
watch this everybody's watching go to
Amazon or your local book store Barnes
and Nobles calm and pick up the
blueprint Doug Amy thank you so much
you